the standard the usual suspects all the
great dead white males then you know
some women everyone you know everyone
from yukio mishima the japanese writer
Knut Hamsun the Norwegian writer the
living writer I admire the most don't
know if he influences me much but who in
VII is JM Coetzee the South African will
now Australian writer it's amazing what
he does with so few words the most
monumental book I've ever read I believe
would be the Divine Comedy by Dante I
love all the Russians dust CFC to me is
not necessarily a great novelist but
he's a great writer Tolstoy is both a
great writer and a great novelist but I
also like the sort of the slightly
lesser known you know Turgenev Gogol
Goncharov all of those you know the
usual nineteen you know that either the
the apogee of english-language writing
was 20 and 19th century English writing
those great you know naturalistic
writers like thomas hardy charles
dickens joseph conrad and then moving on
to 20th century American literature so
there are the usual suspects you know
the Hemingway's Faulkner Sinclair Lewis
all of those Willa Cather you know so
all those you know i-i've know I can't
say there's any writer you know in
Beatrice and Virgil III I use flowback I
used you to hole the play within the
novel is very mad enough in a Beckett
kind of mode but none of those are gods
to whom I kneel every day each has their
strengths each has their weaknesses
maybe letting go like go at it and then
or maybe take a break not let go but
take a break try to figure it out and
then take a break then get back to it
I'm saying that actually cuz I recently
heard Martin Amos is now is an older
writer
whereas a younger writer he would just
force himself to work through words now
so he has a problem he gets up from his
desk and gives himself time so maybe
that I don't know you know I think
there's no formula to writing so the the
the the key thing I'd say to anyone who
aspires to write would be to read the
best teacher is a cheap little penguin
classic read beyond what you want to
write so if you want to write romance
great but also read science fiction read
classics if you aspire to be a literary
writer if you aspire to be the next John
Updike read Harlequins you know read
outside read beyond the narrow can of
what you what you particularly like so
read read read
it's so damn cerebral you're just in
your head you're in a sitting position
in your head I love the physicality of
dance the the physicality of painting
I love the emotional immediacy of music
it's so in your head so that that drives
me crazy at times I wish it were more
physical which is I suppose why in some
ways I love theatre because it is its
spoken now the playwright is still
sitting but the end product is more
physical so I guess that that is very
now I say that in the converse is that
it's I think there's no greater
representation of reality than a great
novel nothing can be a great novel
nothing not cinema not music not
painting they all have their strengths
but if you want to capture a past
reality you know rush in the 19th
century nothing will do it better than a
great novel by Tolstoy it'll give you
it'll capture that past reality better
than a painting better than a symphony
nothing can beat a great great novel it
is the greatest mode of representation
it doesn't mean it's the favorite one
it's a real engagement it's a real
commitment to want to read war and peace
you may want a symphony instead you may
find a painting more comforting so so
that's the converse side of it being
very cerebral
we are story animals so the best part of
writing is that you are in story and as
I said earlier I talked about religion
and art I think they're two very well
together
stories at their greatest our religious
not explicitly so but stories at their
greatest define who we are as a species
we are story animals leopards pandas
koalas lizards are not story animals
they have no stories we have stories and
that makes us unique and that's what
we're entirely about we are not economic
animals although we do have economies
we're not political animals or that we
do have politics at the saddest saddest
thing in human terms is that a human
being who has no stories because
assuming who has no stories is someone
who has not been loved and has not been
able to love as soon as you engage
yourself in being human you start
developing stories not necessarily good
stories it could be mere anecdotes they
are part they are starting to be part of
who you are